today on the matt welsh show the media
calls the race for joe biden
with uh counts still ongoing and the
winner not actually determined biden
delivered a victory speech where he
called for
quote-unquote unity the democrats want
to be pals again now that they
think they've won and i'll explain why
their gestures of friendship
are pretty meaningless also five
headlines including
the death of an icon uh and a very a
very coincidental
coveted miracle that's happening that we
have to talk about as well plus our
daily cancellation and much more
we start here with the events of
saturday you know with with the council
ongoing as i said in a recount in
georgia not even started
legal challenges still being mounted in
other words when the matter of who
actually won the election was still
very much up in the air the media
decided that it seen enough and declared
joe biden
the winner now as to this decision i
will maintain my radical stance that we
can
never know who won any election until
all
legal votes have been counted and
accusations of improprieties have been
investigated and litigated um that
hasn't happened yet in this case
so we remain in limbo whether the media
chooses to acknowledge it or not
but none of that stopped joe biden from
taking to the stage delivering his
victory speech
a speech that i thought was breathtaking
in its dishonesty phoniness
arrogance granted that dishonesty
phoniness arrogance
this is the general tenor of almost any
political victory speech or political
speech of any other
any other kind but this one managed to
raise the bar
by several notches i think let's listen
to uh some of the speech i'm sorry to do
this to you but uh
i must so let's let's listen tonight
we're seeing all over this nation all
cities and all parts of the country
indeed across the world an outpouring of
joy
of hope renewed faith and tomorrow bring
a better day
okay let's stop it there for just a
moment uh yes about that about that
outpouring of joy in cities across the
country
it was an outpouring of something
certainly joy is one word for it not the
word i would use but one word
here's footage of one such outpouring
this is in dc thousands of people all
crammed together i'm told there was a
lot of dancing in the street
they were so happy they were dancing
good for them
i guess if you're a business owner in
one of these cities you'd rather have
them
drinking in celebration from the wine
bottles than lighting them on fire and
throwing them through your windows so
that's an improvement but of course
the question does arise as you look at
these images did joe biden defeat kovitt
that quickly
i knew it'd be quick i mean he did
promise to shut down the virus i just
didn't think it'd take him take him 30
minutes to do it that's pretty
impressive
or is this yet another example of the
chronovirus being
politically enlightened you know we
already knew that it will spare you if
you're a blm activist or a mourner at a
funeral for a prominent democrat
will also pass over you like the angel
of death in egypt if you're expressing
joy about donald trump
allegedly being voted out of office is
this
you know the coronavirus being
politically enlightened or even just
kind of chill
maybe it's going hey you know they're
having a good time i'm not gonna go
getting them all sick and stuff bro
let's
let's not ruin the party okay now i i
can
make a joke about it but it's actually
not funny especially if your child has
been going to school on his computer for
a year
not getting a real education or your
grandfather had to die alone with no
visitors or
your business was destroyed all of that
had to happen they told us to keep us
safe
but these clowns can have their party in
the middle of the street
oh and remember a lot of these people
are the same ones
who were too afraid to go to the polls
to vote they were too afraid to
participate in the election in person
but not too afraid to celebrate the
ostensible result of the election in
person
right it's a farce it's a travesty
speaking of farces back to
joe's speech i pledge to be a president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states of blue
states only sees the united states
and work with all my heart with the
confidence
of the whole people to win the
confidence of all of you
and for that is what america i believe
is about
it's about people and that's
what our administration will be all
about i sought this
office to restore the soul of america
to rebuild the backbone of this nation
the middle class
and to make america respected around the
world again
and to unite us here at home now parts
of that were
indecipherable uh par for the course of
course he's a dementia patient and it
was past sundown but
from from what i could gather biden
wants to unite us
heal us bring us together and quote
restore
our soul i'm not sure how a soul is
restored much less how a president can
do it is it something
that you do through executive order
legislation the soul restoration act of
2021 is that what's coming
but let's not get bogged down on the
details i guess the point simply is that
we didn't have souls before and now we
do because a 78 year old career
politician
says he's our new president you know
there's this long-standing theological
debate very interesting about insolent
um when does the soul enter the human
body is it at conception some other
point
well it turns out it's not conception
it's election the election of joe biden
that's how we all get souls
good to have that sorted out finally now
joe believes
he's onto something with this schtick
he's been tweeting like a fortune cookie
for the past 48 hours declaring that
we're now
united strengthened healed
we have full hearts and steady hands he
said we are running arm in arm through
fields of daffodils
rainbows stretched across the sky
unicorns fly overhead
all is right in the world now because
uncle joe is here to sniff our hair
and tell us it's okay the media has
dutifully latched on to this theme as
well a time to heal
announces the time magazine cover and
the
vaguely sentient bag of farts new york
mayor bill de blasio
also came out to celebrate our
liberation by joe biden and
our opportunity to heal here's what he
had to say
liberation it's just joyous people have
felt this weight
and a sense of we're divided and we we
shouldn't be that way and now there's a
feeling that anything's possible that we
can heal again that we can move forward
and look joe biden and kamala harris did
something amazing
this is turning out to be a huge victory
all over the country
but it's also the beginning of the
healing that's what we need in this
country this city everywhere
but you know it's an odd thing this
healing this unity this liberation
even as biden lays his healing hands
upon us
and keeps them there for an
uncomfortably long time other democrats
like alexandria case or cortes
are busy compiling enemies lists of
people who supported trump something
called the trump accountability project
has been formed
for the purpose of blacklisting anyone
who committed the crime of wrong think
over the past four years
it appears that before we can hold hands
and and amid the flowers and sing our
songs of joy
a few say 70 million or so heretics must
be burned at the stake
joe forgot to mention that part the
healing will commence only after his
enemies have been brought before him in
slain
but i suppose that doesn't sound quite
as inspiring in a speech and that's all
this unity and healing stuff really is
it's
fodder for speeches and these are
speeches given by a man
who belongs to the ideological and
political club which has
for the past several years insisted that
all of their opponents are bigots
racist or worse and not worthy of
acceptance in polite society
anyone who threatens their agenda or
defies their wishes can be slandered
smeared ripped to shreds
labeled a gang rapist even if that's
what it takes and he will deserve
it because he is in fact worse than a
gang rapist
he is in he's an inconvenience to them
in recent months they've taken this
machiavellian gospel to the streets
burning and looting
making victims of their fellow americans
none of whom did anything in particular
to incur their wrath
these are people who will tell you that
if you belong to a certain race
white and sex male you are
fundamentally and irretrievably broken
you are
racist by your very nature probably
sexist too
and they've told us we can't come
together under the flag or as americans
because america is systemically racist a
global disgrace
its heroes are all monsters whose
monuments must be defiled and destroyed
but now a man steps out from among this
group of marauders and bullies and
arsonists and thieves and smear
merchants
and bids us to unite unite around what
for what what commonality what shared
sense of purpose what universal goal or
value
is supposed to bind us together right
now joe
i wouldn't know how to unite with joe
biden and his ilk even if i wanted to
which frankly i don't
mainly because i know the answer to my
own questions
we are meant to unite in submission
to the democrat party and its doctrines
we are meant to come together
around the democrats and their hollow
vessel of a leader to say
congratulations
and hooray and we agree and about four
or five other approved
sentiments this is the unity for which
joe biden pleads
i have won so now we can be friends as
long as you follow the orders
he he says to us with a magnanimous
smile
well call me ungrateful but i don't find
this pitch very appealing
nor believable i don't like division but
i'll take it over a false and empty
unity
around a false and empty man
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
all right so uh as you can see by the
way in the in the new digs here
the uh the studio so come up in the
world from from the car
to here and the great thing is uh they
did a great job putting the studio
together and
the other the other great thing is if
you're watching on on youtube
or dailywire.com uh maybe you can see i
have these prop
photographs here and they've actually
given me i don't know if you can see it
on camera but they've given me a family
this is not i don't know who these
people are but i've been assigned to
family as well here in nashville
this is a a man and woman on a tandem
bike with a picnic basket
biking through a field that's not me i'm
not i'm not much for tandem bikes
not that nor am i a picnic guy but um
anyway that's my new
nashville family so that's great um and
uh excited to be here in nashville
let's let's start here with with news
that's actually very sad
number one alex trebek maybe you heard
yesterday has died he was 80 years old
diagnosed several months ago with cancer
um you know i have to tell you celebrity
deaths
very rarely affect me on an emotional
level but this one does because alex
trebek was a legend he was an icon just
sort of this
grandfather-like figure who you see on
tv every night
uh in a lot of ways he was kind of like
mr rogers
i think a mr rogers for adults and i
i mean that is the utmost compliment
because mr rogers was great too
trebek was um similar as well in the
fact that he was a universally beloved
public figure
one of the very last on earth so now i'm
thinking to myself
how many universally beloved people
do we have left in america and i know
that alex trebek was technically
canadian right so but i'm claiming him
for america
for these purposes we have certainly
adopted him into our family uh so
with with him passed away how who's left
i'm talking about people who no matter
what side of the political aisle you're
on
everybody likes you uh
world you know universally renowned
nobody thinks you're problematic
because in order to achieve that now and
we may be entering a point in american
culture
i'm certain i'm certain we are at this
point where nobody can be that way
anymore
but a few people got grandfathered in
because they they'd um
just always been you know one of the
universally beloved people
regis philbin you know we lost him too
uh
now so who's left now that we've lost
alex trebek betty white i guess is is
one
keanu reeves he's younger we'll have him
for a while i'm not sure
just to show you just to make the point
of uh how beloved this man was trebek
had and i i learned this
through reading uh one of the obituaries
for alexandria i think this is on cnn
of course of course on cnn because they
had to mention this alex trebek
apparently had
one public controversy his entire career
this guy was you know in in on on camera
like every day for 40 years or something
and he had one public controversy
that they did mention in the cnn
obituary because of course they did
and the controversy i didn't even hear
about this when it happened it happened
recently
the controversy is that in the year 2018
he moderated
a pennsylvania governor's race debate
gubernatorial debate
and uh the controversy was that
apparently trebek
was cracking jokes the whole time and
quizzing the candidates as if they were
on jeopardy i watched one of the clips
he was quizzing them
about their knowledge of uh of
philadelphia eagles trivia
so and that was a controversy some
people were upset about that that makes
me
love him even more that's awesome he's
one public controversy and it's great
i'll have to dig that up and watch that
uh debate for old time's sake all right
number two
fox news reports one of joe biden's
first priorities as president-elect will
be implementing mass
mandates nationwide by working with
governors
the future 46th president uh allegedly
however says if they refuse then he will
go to mayors and county executives and
get local masking requirements in place
let me just say this is if they go this
route with a with a national mass
mandate
which of course he has no authority
whatsoever to do that
what where does the president derive the
authority
to tell 330 million people across the
country that they have to wear a certain
thing on their face
he does he derives it from his own
imagination his own increasingly
confused and deluded imagination
that's where he gets it so yes if if
this is what he tries to do
and i'm sure it will be he has no
authority to do it
and this will be i'm sure if if we do
have a joe biden administration
this will be one of many absurd and
illegal orders
from that administration that i will be
simply ignoring
and that's that's the right thing to do
when the president tells you this is
what you have to wear on your face every
time you leave your house
the appropriate response is to laugh in
his face and just
ignore it okay what do you what are you
doing you're gonna send the national
guard into every uh
what i mean what you said in the
military across the country
making sure people are wearing masks go
ahead go ahead
go ahead and enforce that one
in in general i mean even if it's not
the president telling you to do it
whoever's doing it if they're telling
you to wear a mask
when you leave your house if you're
outside even
that's something to just simply totally
ignore
number three um this is real
okay not a hint of irony washington post
reports this is the headline for biden
fans
one unifying standard old glory
like i was talking about what are we
uniting around like he's talking about
unity so what is what's the what is the
unifying standard well the washington
post says
old glory the american flag that's
that's that's the unifying standard
um and here's here's the what they say
they say if there was one enduring
listen i can barely even read this if
there was one enduring
symbol of joe biden's nationwide
election night party saturday night
it was the american flag in the
riverfront district of wilmington near
the parking lot from which biden
delivered a speech to the nation
flags flew everywhere there was a big
flag a massive old glory
hoisted between two cranes invisible
from the interstate it flew for a week
as the ballot count agonizingly
continued
um and uh okay i'm not even going to
read this entire thing
the point is in this in this article
they're
claiming that now the democrats
are bringing the american flag back
they're bringing it back as a symbol
right but the chris i don't need to
explain why that's completely ridiculous
these are the people who've been telling
us that we should not be saluting or
standing for the flight
they've been protesting the flag for the
last four years and longer than that
and now they're telling us that oh
actually no the american flag is our
symbol that's
we're bringing it back we're gonna make
it trendy again
and and here commences the process by
the media
to pretend that so much of what happened
over the last four years
didn't happen we're going to watch so
many things getting memory hold
and one of them is the flagstone because
now if we have a democrat president
now you're allowed to respect the flag
again now we can celebrate now we can
all stand teary-eyed
before the flag stand for the national
anthem
because there's a democrat in office now
it's okay
and of course of course that's how the
left sees it because they don't they
don't recognize
um they don't see any deeper
greater significance to the country
other than the government you know the
government is the ultimate
reality and so that's what
the flag stands for this is what they've
never understood
the flag doesn't stand for the
government
it's it it stands for the the deeper
things that america is supposed to
symbolize things like freedom
self-sacrifice liberty
that's what the flag really does stand
for they don't see it that way they
think that it's all about the government
and so as long as the government is
being controlled by the
right people quote unquote then we can
respect the flag that's how they see it
um number four
this is from who's this
yahoo news says jill biden jill biden
the
the supposed first lady to be
a chance to transform the role of first
lady
and there have been there have been many
articles about this in the last couple
days this on yahoo news about how jill
biden's gonna
jill biden is going to transform the
role of the first lady and it's going to
be a whole new thing with the
i i i just i i just wanted to say this
just just an idea
here's my idea for the role of the first
lady um
no role at all that's that's the role of
the first lady that i would like to see
i i i would love if we get if we get to
the point where we don't need to give
the first lady
these these little projects to do where
we pretend that
she plays a significant role in
government
this whoever it is the spouse of the
president has
has no power no relevance to the
government whatsoever
so if we could get to the point where we
stopped doing that with the first lady i
think that would be great
that's the transformational first lady
role i would like to see
where the first lady just doesn't do
anything because she wasn't elected
um okay number five finally from the ap
a miracle has occurred
um a miracle and a great coincidence i'm
sure just a coincidence
it says pfizer said monday that an early
peak of the data on its carnivirus
vaccine suggests
uh the shots may be a robust 90 percent
effective
at preventing coven 19 putting the
company on track to apply later this
month for a emergency use approval
from the fda the announcement less than
a week after presidential election
that was seen as a referendum on
president donald trump um
comes and so on and so forth
pharmaceutical companies of various
countries are in a global race to
develop a vaccine a vaccine against the
virus
dr bill gruber pfizer senior vice
president of clinical development told
the associated press
we're in a position potentially to be
able to offer some hope we are very
encouraged
yeah this is a miracle that
joe biden announces his victory on
saturday
and on monday we hear news of a 90
effective vaccine i mean you have to
have the iq
of of like a clump of sand to think
that this is not a coordinated thing
the idea that's a cool that it's a
coincidence
that now we're hearing about this
vaccine right when the election
concludes
immediately after joe biden gets up and
says i'm the winner
now we hear about the vaccine no i'm
sorry
the the timing of this is clearly
politically
um is clearly political
you know and now the the thing is
of course whoever the president is
i personally am i don't care who the
president probably are democrat
i personally i'm not going to give the
president any president credit for a
vaccine because the president isn't in
the
isn't in the lab with a lab coat doing
the clinical trials and coming up with a
vaccine right
um so that's i i i wouldn't give a i
wouldn't give a lot of credit to any
politicians for that
that goes to the people who actually
made the vaccine who are not politicians
but even so you know if it had been
announced
imagine this imagine if two days before
the election
this announcement had been made
whether you give trump credit for it or
not it's a it's positive it gives you
hope in fact that's what
that's what uh dr bill gruber says we're
in a position offer some hope we can be
very encouraged
and if people are hopeful and they're
encouraged
and they're going to vote on election
day they're more likely to vote for the
incumbent everybody knows that
but of course the media can't allow that
to happen you don't want people to be
encouraged and hopeful
so they wait until a week after the
election to make this announcement it's
completely transparent and uh also
infuriating all right gonna get to our
um
daily cancellation just a second but you
know with this election going on as
and that we've been talking about it's
it's uh we try to keep you in the loop
every step of the way it's been it's
been
a hell of a week for everybody and it's
still too too soon to tell who who will
win
exactly so you can join daily wire right
now get 25
off with code election so you can keep
up with us and on
all the unfolding twists um but not only
that we have big plans
for these next four years regardless of
who the president turns out to be
we're in nashville now and we've got a
lot of things we're going to do i'm
happy to announce that candace owens new
york times bestselling author and
founder of the
blexit foundation will be launching a
brand new show with us early next year
in nashville very excited about that
candace owens is great
and uh as well she'll be writing content
for us over at dailywire.com we'll also
be launching an entertainment channel an
investigative journalism team
building partnerships like with
like-minded content creators like prager
use entire show libraries available
right now on delaware.com
for uh members or or will be by the end
of the year if you become a member again
that's 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today
there's a lot of stuff you can get right
now a lot of really exciting things
going to happen in the future
and if 2020's taught us one thing it's
that anything can happen so you want to
become a member today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
well today we are entering a daily
cancellation
time warp so that we can go back in time
and cancel
every leftist who spent the last four
years in paralyzing despair
and fear and heartache because they
didn't like the president
of course they've already been canceled
automatically many times over on the
grounds of being generally lame and
annoying
but now now i especially have to cancel
them after potentially if the media
declared results stand
potentially that means that i and we
conservatives are experiencing the shoe
on the other foot if biden becomes
president then
we will have lost and now we will have a
president that we don't like
and the left expects that we'll be
weeping in the street the same way they
were
in fact i've heard this over and over
again the last few days the taunts of
how do you like this dose of your own
medicine huh i bet you're crying
yourself to sleep at night
screaming into your pillow just like i
was aren't you i bet your teddy bear is
getting soaked in tears too you loser
doesn't feel too good does it
democratic shill tori on twitter was
doing a lot of this he said this is this
is what he said and
this is part of the unity and healing
we're hearing about this is what it
sounds like from him
he says if you're a trumper i hope the
pain and anxiety you feel now is
excruciating
you voted against america and for a cult
leader who has no redeeming or admirable
qualities
he's a cretan who cares nothing about
this country and you don't either
you deserve all the pain and more
very unifying but see i don't feel pain
right now at all really
in fact i feel fine when i found out
that biden had been declared by the
media to be the winner of the election
i was at the nashville zoo great zoo by
the way
uh on a different day i might have to
cancel though all big cat exhibits at
all zoos
because nobody's ever gone to the tiger
or jaguar
cheetah exhibit at any zoo and actually
seen one
so i'm not sure what the what the
function is they're always like up over
there
way off in the farthest reaches of their
enclosure hiding behind a tree or
something
really tacky way to to treat your guests
i think at least that's what my wife
tells me
anytime she has a friend over and i stay
upstairs the whole time because i don't
like it when strange people are in my
territory
i'm very cat-like myself in that respect
anyway um that isn't the point
the point is we were the alert popped up
on
on my wife's phone we were at the zoo
telling us biden had quote
one and she told me about it and you
know how i responded
this is how i responded i collapsed to
the ground
sobbed uncontrollably then i started
throwing rocks at the lemurs just to let
off some steam
i looted a bunch of plastic animal toys
from the gift shop burned down the dip
and dot stand
you know normal stuff no actually that's
not what happened
in reality she told me the news and my
first response
was okay so let's go look at the
giraffes
and we did go look at the giraffes and
then we left the zoo we stopped
somewhere for lunch
later that day i went to brat to a bass
pro shops
i did weep there but it was out of joy i
was overwhelmed by the sheer beauty and
majesty of the place
my point here is that is that i
continued living my life i continued to
function in society i continue to
have a great many concerns and
priorities that come before politics
and that seems to be how most people on
the right have reacted yeah there's
anger
sure yeah we want to investigate any
potential irregularities or cases of
fraud and yes if biden is our next
president
we will fight his agenda tooth and nail
yes we take this seriously yes
it matters and we know it but we're not
whining
that we're in pain we're not falling to
our knees in the street
screaming at the sky we're not telling
any anecdotes about our allegedly
heartbroken toddlers and how they're
reacting to the news
we're not claiming to be traumatized
we're not becoming hysterical
most of us because we're grown-ups and
we have kids and jobs
i don't really have a job but a lot of
other people do and we have other
responsibilities
and we have neither the interest nor the
time to be curled up in the fetal
position for the next four years
mumbling that the bad scary president
man hurt us
so if these results do stand as cult
i guess i'm supposed to say uh that i
see where the left is coming from
with how they reacted to their to their
loss four years ago
but truthfully i see even less where
they're coming from
i relate to them even less than i did
before
i find their behavior even less
defensible
and as i as far as how i feel about the
possible biden administration
i say bring it if that's the way the
votes go i'm ready to fight the agenda
of oatmeal brain and his marxist
handlers
i'm ready to have it out in the meantime
i've got kids to take care of i've got
chores to do fish to catch
a life to lead and so
all of those people who put their lives
on hold to obsess over trump
are canceled and that's going to do it
for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
[Music]